welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer hardware
anatomy of a laptop so in this video
we're going to take apart
a ibook g4 which was donated by one of
my former tas
normally we take this apart and when i
give one of the tas a video camera which
they
point at the laptop as we dissect it and
we project
from that camera onto the classroom's
main screen so everybody can take
a closer look at what's actually going
on and i passed around the parts
unfortunately that wasn't an option and
i also
don't actually have access to the laptop
itself
so these are all old photographs
currently the gates building is locked
and
none of us are allowed in so let's go
ahead and take a look at our laptop here
so this is an ibook g4 it's
about 15 years old you can also see
it's got a serious case of what it's
sometimes referred to as keyboard plaque
i mentioned this because some of you are
probably looking at this thinking
patrick that's kind of gross and it is
and honestly i should probably take an
industrial strength solvent to it and do
some cleaning because
as we'll see in a minute this laptop is
clearly never going to be used anyway so
it could use some serious cleaning and i
will have to say this is one of those
cases where
apple's white motif here is probably not
doing us any favors
anyway so what we're going to do is
we're going to take off the keyboard
take off the gross keyboard
and it turns out that this particular
laptop is upgradable
and this is something that some of the
larger laptops have
the ability to change and modify some of
the parts
the nice slim sleek laptops do not have
the
generally do not have that ability
usually the parts are
not set up to allow for modularity
instead they're designed to be as
compact as possible and generally
they're not they're not serviceable
okay so this particular laptop
this is old enough so that it did not
actually originally come with
a wi-fi this was an option and so you
could take off the keyboard and there
was a place where you could slip in a
wi-fi card and there's the wi-fi card
right there
not shown right here because there's
actually a metal shield that goes onto
this we'll talk about that in a second
and then underneath where the wi-fi goes
and you can see that this one actually
did have a wi-fi card that's what's
sitting there
um it's been pulled out and then
underneath that that is actually
computer memory so i could go ahead and
add ram to this particular laptop
notice the metal sheeting that is
covering everything other than the
airport extreme wi-fi
card and the memory we're going to go
ahead and flip this over
and in the corner there the missing part
that's actually where the battery goes
but the main thing that i wanted to show
you here is if we pull off the back
again you can see this metal sheeting
all around
the laptop so this this is basically
going to completely surround the laptop
this
is designed as electromagnetic shielding
and it's designed to reduce the amount
of electromagnetic radiation that
comes out of the laptop or that goes
into the laptop
because we don't want the laptop to
interfere with other electronic
devices in the area so for example
you may have seen on various television
shows
the idea that if you've got those rabbit
ear antennas on your television
and you're trying to get the television
to work properly
if you've got some sort of a
electromagnetic motor
or sometimes electronic device it can go
ahead and interfere with it and so
this metal sheet that goes all around
the entire laptop that is designed to
reduce the amount of
electromagnetic radiation coming out of
the laptop and prevent problems like
that
and if we take off the sheeting here on
the
back you can see that's what's
underneath it
we're going to be talking about this
green motherboard here on the left
in a couple minutes but let's go ahead
and flip it over first
okay so this is the the top of the
laptop
what you see on the inset here is this
is the electromagnetic
shielding that is supposed to go on the
top of the laptop i've
actually been removed here and this is
uh this inset is
obviously from another photograph okay
so here's all the different parts right
here
um there are a couple parts that i think
are worth mentioning here and we're
gonna
take a quick look at them in the
overview and then we're going to go into
more detail on each of these
okay so here's a titan shot that
little u-shaped metal object right there
that is actually the wi-fi shield so
that is what it was supposed to be
under the wi-fi card um in the previous
shot when we had just opened up the
keyboard
i don't know why it wasn't in the
photograph but it wasn't in the
photograph but that actually goes
between the memory which was
accessible so you would take off the
keyboard
there would be the wi-fi slot then there
would be this wi-fi
shield and then underneath the wi-fi
shield would be the memory
and the wi-fi card is outside of the
shielding because it does need to send
signals
okay next to it is something called the
heat sink and we'll talk in more detail
about that in a minute
and then underneath or just just
below on the photograph just below the
heatsink
uh is the hard drive or hard disk and
it's actually sitting in the location
where the battery is supposed to go i
don't know why it's sitting there in
this particular photograph the correct
location for it is in the far left
and that orange cabling there is
actually
how data gets on and off the hard drive
that's supposed to be connected to the
hard drive
and then that whole area on the left
side that's the motherboard
and we'll take a look at each of these
in a little bit more depth
and there's the backside view and again
that
motherboard that we're seeing on the
left of the main photograph is the exact
same board as shown on the
in the inset on the backside view of the
laptop
okay so this is a hard drive or hard
disk
the distinction between the drive and
the disk isn't particularly important in
this case but here's the distinction
the drive is the thing that the disk is
contained within
since a hard drive has the disk
permanently
in it hard drive and hard disk are
largely synonymous but you can think of
for example
i have a blu-ray drive which is the
device that i put blu-ray discs
into so in that case the drive is the
the
thing that you put the discs into and
you have a variety of blu-ray discs
the hard drive the disk is permanently
stuck in it so
it's more or less the same you can see
the disk itself here
it consists of a number of different
platters reviewing the top platter right
here
and those platters spin around at very
high speeds
the faster the speed that the platter
spins around the faster we can access
our data
and the more expensive the disc
um these are the read write heads and
they're supposed to be
you can kind of see the the sort of
v-shape
heading in underneath the platter
there's actually supposed to be another
one of those on the top
and that got bent off and broken off
during one of our demonstrations so that
is no longer with us but
basically the tip which is not shown
that's underneath the disc there
that's where the magnetic read write
head goes and
that whole assembly moves in and out
and by moving it in and out and spinning
the disc around
we're able to access every individual
part of the platter
and we can magnetize it or we can read
how that section that this is magnetized
and that's how we're starting our
bits on this particular type of device
okay um so some of you may be like why
are we looking at a hard disk this is
old technology actually it turns out
depending on
what you're trying to do hard disks may
still be more practical than
ssd drives just because they are cheaper
per byte so if you've got a lot of bytes
you may be better for the hard disk so
people will use
hard disks if maybe they've got a lot of
video
um say they're recording lots of
lectures remotely
or probably a better example is they use
it for things like
video surveillance where you have a
constant stream of video coming in you
want to store that all
anything that requires a lot of data
storage it's going to be a lot cheaper
to use a hard
disk or hard drive than it will be to
use a solid state drive
now here's a solid state drive i don't
actually have pictures of these
i don't have an ssd at this point that
i'm prepared to sacrifice for her demos
but it turned out there are a couple
shots on wikimedia commons so
um credits for these photographs will be
at the end of the
presentation uh so this is what the
solid state drive looks like and you can
see
uh the top left view is the external
view and
the bottom right view is when you
actually pull the covers off that's what
what's inside and you can see it looks
very similar to the motherboard
we'll be talking about this in a couple
minutes but that's a printed circuit
board with a bunch of
computer chips on it so basically the
ssd is
pretty boring it's just a whole bunch of
computer chips which actually is
why in many respects the ssd is better
than the hard drive
the chips are much much faster than the
mechanical device
and also it's less susceptible to
things like vibration so like i would
always be nervous
if my laptop had a hard drive in it if i
tried to
use the laptop while i was moving it but
with an ssd there's no moving parts so
it's it's just more reliable and less
things to concern yourself with
okay let's go back to our overview here
and there's a motherboard on the left
and here's a closer view of the
motherboard in the previous shot
the heatsink was not in the proper
position and now the heatsink is in the
proper position that's that big metal
thing in the middle there
you can also see the memory chips just
to the right of it
and we're going to go ahead and take off
the heatsink here
um and so let's talk a little bit about
heat sinks
uh if you look at the image here you can
see that we've got the heat sink
and then up in the top
right hand corner that's actually a fan
and so what the heatsink is doing
is it's actually on top of the chips
on the motherboard that generate the
most heat and you want a heat sink that
is heat conductive so some sort of metal
that can conduct heat really well
and you want it to have the maximum
surface area and then you want to blow
fans on it to try and conduct
the heat away so maximum surface area to
maximize the amount of heat that can
come off of it
and then some sort of a fan system and
so we're seeing here
is you can see that that heat sink from
the laptop that's on the left hand side
of this image here
it actually does connect up to another
big metal section which is right next to
where the fan was and then on the right
side this is an example of a desktop
computer's heatsink very large often
quite heavy
all right we're going back to the
motherboard here and this is underneath
the motherboard
and so we've got a couple of important
chips here
um but let's talk about the motherboard
itself first
so the motherboard itself is what
referred to as a printed circuit board
and we saw a printed circuit board a
minute ago with the ssd drive
so the printed circuit board that it's
basically got that green
substrate that everything's on that is
non-conductive meaning that
electric signals cannot pass through the
green substrate and then what we do is
on top of the green substrate we etch or
laminate on
thin lines of something that can conduct
electricity and that's how we send
signals and electricity through our
computer
and what i've got here is these two
modules down
these two insets down below are actually
showing part of a
memory module and i'm using these
because i had the photographs
and normally we actually take the
motherboard and pass it around so people
can kind of see what it really looks
like
obviously we can't do that but i thought
these two photos did a good job
kind of giving a closer tighter in look
at what the printed circuit board
actually looks like so again there's
that green substrate
and then we've got some computer chips
attached to the printed circuit board
and then you can see we've got these
fine etched
on or laminated on metal lines going
through and that's actually where our
electric signals
go all right so going back to the
motherboard
in the top we have the cpu or central
processing unit
and then at the bottom we have the
graphics chip
these both generate a tremendous amount
of heat
and so that's why we've got the heatsink
over them
here's a shot of a central processing
unit from a desktop computer
we can't actually take the laptop cpu
out so
this is one of my old office computers
cpus cpus for desktop computers are
often upgradable so
they're designed to actually pull off
pull out there's a socket that you can
actually pull the cpu out of and replace
it with a different cpu
laptops are generally not designed for
that and
the cpu is going to be soldered directly
onto
the motherboard but i really like these
shots
it really shows how the information gets
on and off of
the cpu so we see all these pins here
and each of these pins is being used for
one of several purposes
first of all there's a couple pins in
there just for power so
you know our central processing unit
does need power
i should also mention so this is
actually the package surrounding the
actual computer chip
so we can't actually see the computer
chip it is inside the ceramic package
there are thin wires connecting the
actual
chip which is again inside what we're
looking at here there are thin wires
connecting it to each of the pins that
we're actually looking at here
but these pins are used to get power
data and address information and control
information
on and off the cpu so imagine
you know what we talked about earlier
we've got the cpu
it's connected to main memory the cpu
needs to access
data from main memory and so a whole
bunch of these pins are going to send
address information so i'm going to set
the address pins on this saying
hey this particular sequence of bits i'm
about to send down these address pins
that's the address for the particular
byte in memory that i want to access
and then either if i'm doing a read
operation
either memory is going to send the bits
at that particular memory location down
and through
the data pins and i'm going to store
that information in the cpu where i can
access it
or i'm going to go the other way and the
cpu is going to say
okay i've got some information stored in
an internal
data register in the cpu i need to store
that in memory now and so i'm going to
set the address pins to the address of
the set
of the bytes in memory that i want to
store this information in
and i'm going to send the data through
the data pins so there's a whole bunch
of pins
um as we've moved to from 8-bit
computing to 16-bit computing to 32 to
64 bits we need
more and more pins and so that's what
all those pins are doing
okay and then here's our overview again
and the last thing i wanted to mention
is just the memory
so on the right we see
the memory for the laptop and on the top
left we've seen
memory for our desktop computer
these are what are referred to as memory
modules and they're different types of
memory modules
the main point i wanted to make here is
notice how many computer chips there are
here so on the laptop you can count
there's four chips there
and then for the desktop there's eight
often
there's another set of chips underneath
so it's possible with a laptop we've got
four on top there might be another four
underneath
and with the desktop we've got eight
there might be another eight but again
notice these are all powers of two
because everything inside the computer
is done with powerful two and in fact as
we saw previously with those pins coming
out of the cpu
those pins could be on or off the
address pins could be on or off
and so those are going to drive our
binary numbers and our powers of two
inside the computer
okay so that's our last slide i hope
you've enjoyed our little look
at what's actually going on inside of a
laptop